im rheinland-pfälzischen nieder wert hat
der landesbetrieb mobilität eine
sogenannte totholz hecke gebaut aus
gefällten bäumen und sträuchern entstand
hier eine 500 meter lange hecke direkt
am ufer weg doch das ganze ist ein
behördlicher schwarzbau die anlage steht
mitten im flutung und
überschwemmungsgebiet des rheins und
dort ist das bauen gesetzlich verboten
erstes mal eine genehmigung und zum
zweiten mal wenn ich hier wohne und
ortsansässige binden und den rhein ein
bisschen kenne weiß ich was hochwasser
kommt dann wird darin sich viel
verhängen also es ist traurig dass so
was passiert dass die gelder so
verschossen werden
der landesbetrieb mobilität wollte hier
der natur etwas gutes tun
eine totholz hacker als unterschlupf für
vögel insekten mäuse und riegel
es wurden pfähle in den boden gerammt
und die zwischenräume mit grünschnitt
gefüllt das ganze mit drähten gesichert
kosten 25.000 euro aber sollte eine
massive anlage ist hier mitten im
überschwemmungsgebiet des rheins streng
verboten nichts darf hier gebaut werden
was bei hochwasser den abfluss der
fluten behindern könnte so hat die
behörde gesetzeswidrig eine mini
staumauer geschaffen dass das nicht geht
hätte der landesbetrieb natürlich wissen
müssen ja wir waren damals sehr erstaunt
als sie plötzlich da war wenn ich bei
mir ein fenster umbauen will mission
antrag stellen aber hier wird halt
gemacht unnötig einen antrag für den bau
der hacker stellen das hat der
landesbetrieb mobilität tatsächlich
nicht gemacht über die pläne hatte man
ja die genehmigungsdirektion in einem
gespräch informiert und das so dachte
man müsste doch reichen die behörde
kleinlaut dies war ein missverständnis
schriftliche zustimmung bzw
genehmigungen lagen nicht vor
und weiter dass die hecke entfernt
werden muss ist aus sicht des
landesbetriebs bedauerlich ein
bedauerliches missverständnis das den
steuerzahler jetzt noch mal 7000 euro
für den abriss kostet das entscheidende
ist für mich dabei wer trägt die
verantwortung und hat das irgendwelche
co
frequenzen für die verantwortlichen
wieder einfach hin gebaut und gemüse hat
noch bezahlen der der abtransport der
richtig und das entfernen der hecke wird
richtig kompliziert weil inzwischen
viele tiere hier unterschlupf gefunden
haben kann sie nicht einfach weggerissen
werden man muss sie ganz behutsam
abtragen damit der schaden für die natur
nicht noch größer wird